nous avons deux magnifiques produits à
portée de main bonjour je suis le robin
artisan fleuriste gérante du magasin aux
jardins d'oly à aiguille vous a voulu
fermer le magasin pas choix c'est le
règlement qui a eu deux semaines de
flottement
est-ce qu'on peut rouler la troupe à
rouvrir puisque nous ne sommes pas un
commerce de première nécessité et puis
je me suis lancé là repris l'activité en
livraisons pourront pas recevoir du
public
d'autre part le grossiste fournisseurs
subissent le même sort donc ne peuvent
plus être approvisionnées
nous ne pouvons pas rentrer chez eux non
plus pouvoir acheter de la flore et de
la plante
j'ai choisi de mettre en place
uniquement de la vie voir et on va à la
demande des clients aujourd'hui il fait
beau c'est le printemps tout le monde et
continuer chez soi alors j'ai proposé
principalement de la livraison plantes
de jardin et de plants potagers toujours
à se débrouiller
on est des artisans mais voilà la
réouverture des mocistes ce serait bien
et puis aussi laide l'aide de des
communes vous pouvez aussi relayer nos
offres nous informer les habitants et
les locaux de ce qu'on propose
oui ça me permet de de repenser et
surtout ma manière de consommer de
consommer en quarante professionnels à
savoir la fleur qui ne vient pas
forcément de france c'est une erreur
nous avons deux magnifiques produits à
portée de main et que nous les mettrons
pas assez bel et bien déjà eu des
attaques ans j'ai un peu peur de la
hausse des prix pour pouvoir rattraper
la perte qui a été subie j'ai peur des
problèmes économiques
j'ai peur que le fait que les gens
soient restés confinés chez eux ça
l'aurait saleuses et inciter à commander
sur internet et à ses livres et vous
principalement par des grandes firmes
étrangères
alors il ya deux points très importants
la digitalisation et la cohésion la
digitalisation il est très très
important aujourd'hui d'avoir une
présence sur internet
aujourd'hui le consommateur veut tout et
tout de suite à n'importe quelle heure
il faut pouvoir être présent pour
pouvoir répondre à cette demande
un site internet un compte instagram à
une page facebook boutique en ligne
je ne me fais pas partir mais au moins
de ce ces choses là et ça va vous
permettre de pouvoir vous faire
connaître et d'avoir un rayonnement
encore plus là ensuite vint cohésion la
cohésion je trouve que aujourd'hui dans
le métier et d'artisanat il est très
important de se serrer d'avoir un réseau
de un réseau de collègues de confiance 1
qui travaillent ensemble parce que
ensemble on est plus fort en ce qui me
concerne tout simplement consommer local
je l'avais déjà mon producteur de
plantes ça c'est pas de souci mais
surtout au niveau de la fleur coupée
consommer local en a de très très beaux
produits en france et en ile de france
surtout en et salons à des producteurs
de plantes et de fleurs qui font de
superbes produits et aujourd'hui je vais
choisi de mettre toute cette production
est que ce savoir-faire en valeur il est
important de consommer local et
artisanat nous remettre en valeur le
savoir faire et les laitiers les
artisans français des artisans qui se
moquent porte et qui travaille pour vous
tous les jeux sans compter pouvoir aussi
sauvegarder des emplois sauvegardés des
métiers arrêt confirmant je vais au
restaurant je suis voir ma famille on va
aussi travailler proposer de nouvelles
choses et mettre en valeur notre savoir
[Musique]